Kitty hey hey Kitty
tu vas bien
je faisais encore ce truc n'était-ce pas ouais
tu l'étais Je me souviens d'avoir déjeuné
avec Jim il a commencé à parler de ce
genre de fille de la forêt qui avait un
don spécial de connexion avec les êtres vivants
et elle va  avoir environ 14 ans et toi
et moi savons à quel point tu es immature donc je
pense que tu peux gérer ça
j'ai dit Merci quand tu vois Sigourney
jouer un personnage qui a le quart de son
âge réel parfaitement elle s'est imprégnée
des manières des adolescentes salut maman mais
inconsciemment  elle est juste devenue plus jeune
et c'était fou d'observer pourquoi je ne peux pas
être comme tout le monde oh d'accord je
ne pense pas qu'aucun d'entre nous soit très loin
de nous-mêmes de 14 ans c'est un
souvenir si fort à quel point c'était génial et  à quel point
c'était horrible et je suis juste tombé
amoureux du personnage Jim a cette
incroyable capacité à écrire directement dans
le cœur d'un personnage pourquoi suis-je
différent la capture de performance donne aux
acteurs la possibilité de jouer des
personnages qu'ils ne pourraient pas
jouer autrement et Kyrie  Le personnage et
la performance de Sigourney sont l'
exemple parfait de celui donné par l'une des
grandes actrices de notre époque, bien sûr,
ils l'ont emmené J'ai dû travailler
complètement différemment de ce que j'ai jamais fait
auparavant parce que vous devez enlever
tout ce Sigourney Weaver qui que ce soit
c'est-à-dire et ça a été une
expérience incroyable de remonter dans le temps et d'être
avec cette personne chaque jour, elle clique
sur le personnage qu'elle est et c'est
comme parler à une jeune fille de 14 ans, je trouve
fascinant qu'elle puisse canaliser cette
jeune fille quoi qu'il en soit  c'est que j'aime
le regarder c'est comme ça que son nom battait son
cœur sonner comme puissant
elle est merveilleuse de la regarder c'est une telle
œuvre d'art que vous regardez comme une
fleur se dérouler et tout d'un coup vous
ne reconnaissez pas que vous parlez à un
une femme qui a 5 10 ans.
qui a marché sur cette Terre pendant des décennies
et qui a fait sa marque là-bas est si clairement
une petite fille espiègle à Sigourney,
elle peut être aussi impérieuse que vous le souhaitez et
elle peut aussi être un crétin complet,
c'est un grand voyage pour elle et  pour le
public avec elle parce que ça va
parce qu'elle se soucie d'elle elle a une
qualité lumineuse de la voir jouer un
gamin de 14 ans c'était magique c'est ce qu'est le
jeu d'acteur le seul tour d'Avatar
l'obtient
[Musique]